[Applause]
happy wednesday everybody
so president biden is in deep trouble
the white house reports he's testing
negative for kovid which proves even the
virus wants someone else
and according to a new cnn poll over
three quarters of respondents don't want
him to run for president they want him
to run for the hills
the poll comes as his approval ratings
plunge like nancy pelosi's neckline
and most americans
are as disgusted with the economy as
they are
with nancy pelosi's
neckline of course there is no recession
they say as they try to redefine the
term recession the way they redefined
riots and women and crime and basic
biology
we'd say that lie takes some balls but
we don't want to misgender it
it's getting so bad mayor pete is
polling better than joe and pete's
actually done less work on the job than
kamala has on closing the border
pete's now in his 10th month of parental
leave and will be ready to work
full-time once he stops lactating
but i get it joe does not look good
literally and figuratively the only
thing holding him together is the hair
plugs
and you can see why
here's a 20-second clip of biden coming
from the white house look how much
it was edited
this law does so much more
it saves lives including yours
it'll help you do your job
but it's just a start
last week i rolled out my save for
america plan with the goal of doing
three key things first
take additional common sense steps to
reduce gun crimes and violence
they spent more time editing that
20-second clip than coppola did the
godfather both one and two
but at least when dr frankenstein pieced
together his monster he put in a brain
i mean if you have to do that much
surgery for 20 seconds of tape that's
like starting with a six ton piece of
marble and ending up with a bowling
trophy
it's the creepiest presidential eclipse
it's a the zebruder
oh
that upsets you
i'm sorry dark humor today and take a
look at this comparison appearing on
twitter where i get all my research hey
it works for the washington post
it shows two different bidens apparently
24 hours apart
folks as we fight inflation you can't be
pro-insurrection and pro-cop bringing
down gas prices is a big part of the job
you can't be pro-insurrection and
pro-democracy you can't be
pro-insurrection and pro-american and
here's the good news
gas prices have dropped every day this
summer
that's more than 40 days in a row donald
trump lacked the courage to act we now
have 40 000 gas stations in the united
states where the price of gas is 3.99 or
less the brave women and men in blue all
across this nation
should never forget that
wow what the hell is going on
i mean that's the same guy i mean yet
they're as different as night and a
toilet seat
one minute he's fine the next he has the
delivery you'd expect from a p.o.w video
they should have them hold up a copy of
usa today so we have proof of life
what's going on joe
oh no no i'm not working hard i'm hardly
working don't you i'm not just a
professor a professor of political
philosophy at penn let me tell you
something that's all a bunch of poppy
seed
listen to my wife all right she's a
doctor i set it to my
cream of wheat this morning
soon
to do the raccoon
come on man
no wonder no wonder the dams want to
ditch joe faster than a masseuse with
rough hands and monkey pox
the guy's deteriorating faster than joy
behar's mood when she runs out of pie
maybe it's covid that's messing joe up
but it's not like we were blessed with a
fit specimen the guy started out bad now
he's worse i mean even his body double
looks exhausted
i hope for the sake of america and the
planet he's okay
because if he's not this is what we got
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah it sucks
yet it seems the press still seems more
consumed by the past meaning donald
trump and i get it it's the old hey
don't look there look over here trick
but at least trump can complete
sentences has ideas about crime and
homelessness and isn't kept chained to a
radiator somewhere in the west wing
being force-fed adderall in his oatmeal
you know i wonder what would trump do if
he were a basketball coach of a women's
team would he ever
lose if i were a basketball coach of a
woman's team i would
never ever lose i'd be the greatest
coach of all time i'm not a fan of
lebron james at all but i would go to
lebron did you ever think of becoming a
woman did you ever because i'd like to
have you on my team you look at the
tents and the homeless
and you say what's happening to this
great bastion create
thousands and thousands of high quality
tents which can be done in one day one
day
and you have to move people out the ones
that don't have a drug problem
are those that institute a very quick
trial death penalty sentence for drug
dealers
you know it's good to see he had some
change
he still has the subtlety and restraint
you'd expect from a man with his name on
buildings golf courses and stakes you
know any steak with the name biden on it
would come pureed in a squeeze tube
but the dems need help right maybe
they're not looking hard enough
but you know i think i can help i think
i have their candidate this guy
john hinckley
yeah he's out of jail now and here's
what he just tweeted
i believe in peace love equity lgbtq
rights abortion rights animal rights
race mixing assault weapon ban sharing
the wealth green new deal black lives
matter prison reform and good rock and
roll
john join the john hinckley community
yeah it's located at the corner of
crazy boulevard and ahole avenue
but damn he's nuttier now than when he
shot reagan meaning he sounds like the
perfect woke democrat are you sure that
is an aoc in a fat man's suit
he ticked every box
although oddly he did forget handguns
but i guess they must have had cnn on
the prison tv because he sounds no
different than don lemon
and that is cnn's rating strategy show
it where you can't change the channel
talk about cruel and unusual punishment
that's like telling a guy on death row
to share his last meal with brian
stelter
but this loser illustrates a key point
these days you want the press and the
libs to like you just toe the woke line
and anyone can do it even a failed
assassin with an acoustic guitar and a
face like a lumpy potato
hinckley's living his best life
but i don't want to be around when he
hears the news that jodie foster is gay
[Laughter]
so there you go democrats you wanted a
big name you got one a celeb who appeals
to all your little identity cults and he
can sing there's so much anger
in the world
i wanna see some love
everybody seems to be
such a world
i wanna see some love
yeah
there's no cat stevens
closer to cat food
but he sure beats this
[Applause]
let's not forget this guy
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's a reference
so what do you say democrats hinckley
hinckley2024 you can't be that much
worse than what you got his campaign
slogan could be give me a shot
i just might blow you away
let's welcome tonight's guests
his last job was as a mannequin for
j.crew host of the guy benson show guy
virtue
signed with the nfl played superman on
tv and dated brook shields but other
than that he's done nothing impressive
actor and producer dean kane
she's like the girl next door if you
live next to a women's prison boxer's
contributor cat tip
and
finally his footprint has three time
zones my massive sidekick in the nwa
world television champion tyrus
that was a very dark model
it's guy town again i know you like how
much you love all the guy town videos it
is guy town yeah so i wrote one you
wrote a guy
all right let's see it
guy towns suppressing all your feelings
cause you're scared to cry and your dad
was mean talking you talk about your
problems cause he won't judge you we
live in a world where men can't fully
express themselves
[Applause]
i don't like that one
that was i felt like i was attacked but
it's true we have guys here tonight so
one of my favorite guys dean cain um
so how you doing i'm doing great first
of all congratulations to you for
crushing late night
i live in that
bastion of wokeness called hollywood and
to see you on top uh really really and
they don't talk about this show never
they can't talk about it because it's
too humiliating you know i'll talk about
it yes thank you because you're superman
yes no not anymore so what how do you
feel about joe what's uh here's the
question what's in the worst condition
joe or his party kind of tough it's
i would say joe really i'm gonna have to
go with that i mean looking at that
video that video which was edited i
think you were counting four or five
times yeah it was every sentence yes
that was scary scary stuff and what i've
noticed on twitter is they've made it
very clear during that one
very very
froggy voiced
bit he uh he never blinks yeah he never
blinks it is a hostage video yeah yeah
yeah
so that that is it's it's scary to me i
wish it weren't the case it's actually
sad for our country that that's the guy
leading it but uh yeah especially when
you have you know who's in the dugout on
deck a little baseball phrase there yeah
yeah very little that's that's that that
and that laugh i just can't
it does things to the back of my neck
i can't i can't
so guy uh what is your prediction for
2024 and welcome to the show by the way
i'm glad you shaved your beer
you asked me to so yes
your show so it's fine it was leaving a
rash so
by the way i bet you the white house
[Laughter]
yeah sorry this this is long established
this is long established not even news
anymore uh i'm waiting for the white
house to come out and tell us that that
was all shot in one take yes right
because they'd be like well we're just
redefining one take
so that's what it was right that's what
they would do can i come like comment
briefly on john hinckley yeah still hung
up on that part of the model crazy yeah
so
this is maybe a a bit of a controversial
opinion
but i believe that if you attempt to
assassinate a president of the united
states i'm okay with you being canceled
forever right like i'm not in favor of
cancel culture but for that type of
person yes and just to feel like you can
get back in the good graces of polite
society by just vomiting out every woke
platitude it's probably not a dumb move
on his part it'll probably work to some
extent but i'm in favor in this one
instance of canceled culture it's a high
bar but he met it joe that he had a
concert in brooklyn and so he actually
was able to get a gig sold out yeah sold
out but then i then after outcry they
canceled it so it was cancelled
hey there you go i support that one
counselor there you go fine there you go
you're a little bit woke on this no but
you're right you're right he knew what
to do it was totally calculated tyrus
right yeah like he had everything in
there he missed the ukraine you know
but i was i was taken aback and kind of
shocked i didn't know that race mixing
was a bad thing all the time
i didn't know that was on the docket
somewhere i know the people who are up
in arms about all this race mixing
who even uses that phrase i didn't know
about i was like wait a minute he was in
prison for decades
no yeah it's still he went in it was
like no race mixing and he came out
what happened to the no race mixer so
that would be great great to him coming
out and wanting things that were to be
legal that are legal
it's like i mean what
and
here's the deal this is hey this is
where progressive woke bites you on the
ass a little bit i'm just curious of the
editor what group they were representing
the first of and the shoulders to
represent how we're going to edit films
because i'm pretty sure my
eight-year-old
drunk could edit better yeah than that
that was either intentional like we
gotta get rid of this guy right because
they weren't even the same shot no no no
it was close up back away close up
they're literally telling you this guy
can't complete a sentence
it was like their hostage note to the
rest of us like
he he can't even get through a sentence
yeah it was it was better that editor
someone needs to be watching out for
them did you guys unless they were race
mixers
did your heartbeat a little bit when you
were listening to trump like oh my god
that i'm saying i missed that and i
missed the unique ideas i just started
laughing about lebron james it was
killing me just the fact that heroin a
president who can have a complete
sentence and shift a train of thought is
kind of is kind of cool yeah and
on purpose yeah yeah shift the chain of
thought on people and when he says i
don't know we know he's being sarcastic
yeah
i don't know if you you know like
when he says it really he doesn't know
what cat what do you think about uh
hinckley 2024 uh would you support
well i think he actually might have a
shot
like not in a pun way i would never do
that that's all you
um
because when i saw the rundown for this
today i like i googled john hinckley i
was like i was like there's no way that
i i thought i was having a stroke
because i thought i was certain i knew
who this was yeah but i was like it
couldn't be that same guy if this is
what's happening yeah but it was
so maybe that could happen on a larger
scale where people would be like oh it
couldn't possibly be that john hinckley
and they'd just vote for him yes
but i think i might be the only one that
is suggesting this as an idea but it was
based on that tweet that just completely
like it was so brazenly virtue signaling
yeah you know but yeah he has no shot in
the democratic primary though because
he's apparently a straight white dude
with a guitar yes like it's the whitest
name ever comes out as non-binary yes oh
that's if he runs with the juice
[Laughter]
oh wait that's race mixing
nicely done well hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else